[Music]
an innovative member of the u.s air
force is spreading joy and honoring her
colleagues with her creations
using a commonly used military item she
started a company out of her home in
texas that turns old uniforms
into patriotic reads and she's lifting
spirits
one wreath at a time
air force staff sergeant nicole pompe is
using her hobby
to help bring military careers full
circle
pompei is the founder of wreaths by
nicole which was started unintentionally
after posing a picture of an early
creation to facebook
i was like hey ladies what do you guys
think and 20 females were like
i need one i was like oh uh
not intending to sell these but okay
and my mom was like all right let's go i
got some fabric we're gonna cut a whole
bunch of stuff before you leave
let's do this she fabricates the wreaths
using old military uniforms
some sent in from around the country and
some with plenty of history
when they're like the really old
uniforms like i had to cut these ones up
from 1946 and i was like
oh my god like history but i didn't
yeah it's not good i want to put
a lot of care into it when i make it the
uniform i respect it so much so i want
to make sure that it's a
a good quality product that's going to
bring meaning and like
be worth be worth its money and be worth
its time you put your soul into it
yeah exactly exactly i i love it i love
seeing the reactions of people my
made-up slogan is uh wreaths by nicole p
making mom's cry since july 2020.
250 wreaths later and an inbox full of
requests
their impact is being felt around the
country
retired master sergeant matt law gifted
one to a friend
and fellow service member
she pulled it out of the gift bag and
she just she was flabbergasted by it
because i had her name on it
had a rank you know it was it was the 80
uniform and
seeing how much that it meant to her to
see a symbol of what
she has done for her through her career
something that symbolizes her
service her dedication it made me feel
really good
and without nicole coming up this idea
it never would have came to fruition
[Laughter]
i can't get enough of the reactions of
people
when they receive their reads then it it
it's really heart warming to know that
you
made this thing that caused somebody to
react in such a heartfelt way
um like matthew and his friend i watched
that video
and like she was beyond words and tears
automatically started falling down her
face
and i was like that's why i do it
i love her she's doing a great job she
is it's a lot of work but she says she
does it and she's getting all these
requests she's still fulfilling them
because of that reaction and she says
the requests that really mean the most
to her are from the families of fallen
soldiers
who have their uniforms send them to her
and she's you know
holding that piece of history that that
uniform that that person that soldier
wore when they were fighting for this
country that's a great gift idea
it is that's a great gift she said she
couldn't have done it without her mom
who's a certified craft queen oh and so
mom came in and helped her
get started cool